welcome everybody this is an interesting
mix of people it's my class
business and government yes sir
communism plus a variety of other people
from the Yelp community my class is
getting an extra session this week and
we're not charging them any extra
tuition it's a great pleasure to welcome
powers and no need he has a long history
in Russia which you'll hear about but he
has a longer history at Yale when I came
in was yeah and he spent many years
working and eventually wound up in
charge of Fiat North America right yeah
but as the as communism was collapsing
mr. Gailey dispatched paolo to moscow to
figure in here in 1990 was it 1998 we
nine 90 and 91 she should do business in
in whatever was the Soviet Union was
going to become and power spent three
almost three years yep
living through the collapse of the
Soviet Union the attempted coup against
Gorbachev Yeltsin's outlawing the
Communist Party of the Soviet Union and
the collapse and the collapse of the
country during which period he learned a
lot about the Soviet Union on the
emerging Russian Republic but also
concluded that do not do business there
and left and went back to Italy for a
while but they decided he was done with
the automobile business
going to investment banking and it
wasn't long before he was a partner at
Goldman and spent many years overseeing
their Italian investments and other
European investments but in recent years
Goldman had become increasingly
concerned with their activities in
Russia and so knowing that power had the
history that he did mr. blank fine
persuaded you I guess twisted your talk
power into going back to Moscow and in
their three years almost almost three
years persuaded it's is an understated
way it is under state well either mosque
or attire what's been going on from the
beginning here our chief to to the come
tempie period and he's going to talk to
us to know privatization so he's he was
there from the very only privatizations
of this sort describe that you got read
about in in bill bravas before you read
about the morning : that he wasn't
involved in initially down through one
of them own recent privatizations that
Goldman has been involved in and talk
about how is going to talk for about a
half an hour and then we'll open it up
so power welcome and getting some what
you're doing
it's always a pleasure especially for
the people in the back of their own my
voice is usually bad it's very very low
and so if you don't hear very well tell
me and I will try to shout if we are
discussing with you and today sometime
most of the time what you see depends on
where you sit and so ian has given me
has given you some sort of description
of my association with Russia in these
two moments that I have that I've been
associated with Russia call or much of
what I'm going to say and so you should
be able to see my biases looking at the
two periods but please ask me as much as
you want because as you have seen from
the readings everybody was Luke
especially in the last 20 years sees it
totally different things
totally differencing if you take the
three if you take the three readings
they are more or less on very similar
subject more or less than very similar
period you would if it were not on the
title you would not think that it was
the same historical period than the same
nation so and Russia is more is more
true than in any other and any Navy
other of any other nation I know of now
what I would like to start with it's
something very very basic almost very so
basic it's it's it's probably not even
interesting but I think it's going to
give us is going to color everything
that we are going to see this is a
simple reconstruction on of the share of
commodities that are found in Russia
which by the way spends eight times on
the only country
on earth that spans eight times on this
is going to be this is going to be key
in understanding a lot of the singular
bread and in understanding a lot of the
peculiarities of the various types and
the various stages of privatization in
Russia it is also very difficult to
understand the peculiarities of
privatization in Russia if you don't
understand the few things about the
Soviet Union because the Soviet Union
was really a totally peculiar system
which we have not seen in I think in any
other country because I have not done a
lot of work with communist countries at
least not with China I've done some work
with the Central European communist
country and even if they were aping the
Soviet Union to some extent their system
the system of the men or a special
system of management of the economy were
radically different and so in order to
look at some of the characteristic of
the Soviet Union let's let's start let's
I to say they so the Soviet economic
system was considering all of economic
value in production all of it
they were only concerned about producing
about producing goods and the ability of
the consumers to pay for production was
a secondary technical matter actually I
would briefly mention it we can get into
that in in in detail afterward the
Soviet Union was probably the only
economic system where you had
the national currency was divided into
two totally different system
there was one system of supplying
currency to the producer and there was
one system of supplying currency to the
consumer and the way these two system
were balanced was one of the way to
avoid hyperinflation
or to avoid or to have the consumer feel
less disgusted in goods because the
amount of cash that was put in the hand
of the consumer was directly balanced
and proportion on the amount of goods
that were going to be available and so
cash for the consumer and this is
vitally important to understand the
process of privatization and poor soviet
raff cash for the consumer was
apportioned in such a way as to allow
the consumer to buy only the goods that
were going to be offered through the
production system and these and so the
where - there were two totally different
monetary circuits one monetary circuit
based on cash available to the consumer
and one monetary circuit based on
banking available for production
consumer could not have bank accounts
consume the only way in which a consumer
could buy something was through cash or
no checks there were no no bank transfer
cash was really the king for the
consumer bank accounts and bank transfer
were the only way in which the state
allocated resources from the budget for
the producer that was everything else
everything else starts from the users of
the only industrial system
with to monetary circuits these is this
is the key this is the key to everything
as a result of the management of the
economy when you think about a council
of minister you think about a council of
minister where you have Minister of
Foreign Affairs the Minister of
Education the Minister of Defence maybe
you have the Minister of Industry but it
really does not manage anything this is
not the way the Soviet Union was
organized the Council of Minister of the
Soviet Union as you can see had let's
say political or traditional ministers
and it had technical ministers every and
technical ministry were probably four
times as many as the political ministers
and I'm going to reproduce I'm going to
reproduce for you one of the four pages
that were that in a 1980 u.s. manual
were used to describe to picture on two
dimension the Council of Ministers were
soviet union fruit and vegetable
electronic industry electrical equipment
industry
Education civil aviation chemical and
petroleum machine building so most of
the structure of the Council of Minister
was charged with administrative
management of productive activities all
of them are productive activities there
is a minister of fertilizer
wait wait wait wait a second these is
one page of the manual and after you
have another page for the state
committees another page for the Republic
Council of Minister and another page for
the agency
can you imagine they were about 14
million people in the Soviet even
million people in the Soviet Union where
14% of the workforce it was in the
previous life I think were occupied in
manager in the management of economic
activities which meant mostly the
management of production when you think
about this so usually when you think
about organization but in the special
case when you think when you think about
when you think about the Soviet Union
yet to keep on thinking along vertical
lines and the long horizontal lines with
the Soviet Union the Soviet Union's
always a mixture of balance between
horizontal activities and vertical
activity it is even better if you think
about horizontal and vertical or if you
try to think twice for me horizontal and
vertical on a three-dimensional space
if you think that this is the Soviet
Union each one of the sort of cylinder
is the structure of one industry and
this is your vertical space horizontally
you have the territory and horizontally
again you have the regional state
operators the Communist Party apparatus
on top of the state operators and after
you have the Council of Ministers on the
top of the Council of Minister you're
the Presidium of the Politburo so every
every activity and every coordination
goes horizontally and vertically and
goes through administrative structure
industrial structure and political
structure represented by represented by
the comment by represented by the
Communist Party if you go back to our in
your mind if you go back to our first
slide and you think about the natural
resources present in Russia immediately
you can see a very strong identification
between the territorial dimension
horizontal and the vertical dimension
industrial because you can localize
industry in a lot of places you have a
certain degree of flexibility with
almost every type of Industry but when
it gets to Natural Resources you cannot
localize oil where oil is not present
and so when you think that the basis of
the economy was mostly a resource-based
you you have an immediate strong
identification
between this badly drawn cylinder and
the territorial base this is the Soviet
Union and after when the Soviet Union
collapsed that the other pyramid that
you have there all of the party gets
canceled because the part the communist
party is outlawed by Yeltsin immediately
after the attempted coup Gorbachev and
the Soviet Union collapses and you have
the Russian Republic which of course had
horizontal coordination made by the
organs of state that was a lot weaker
that the horizontal coordination of the
Soviet Union because of course the
structure of the Soviet Union we are
much stronger and much more established
than the structure of the Republic and
so these cylinder remained very strong
and since its natural resources industry
based on production they are they have
very strong links with the territory but
the coordination structure of the state
is weak in the coordination structure
and the power structure imposed by the
party Communist Party has disappeared
we follow me so far or am I being too
dense which happens to me very often in
that situation
Yeltsin Gorbachev first and Yeltsin
afterward start and the Reformers guide
our and his group start thinking about
privatizing because of course a system
of coordination that they had before
doesn't work anymore the the structure
or management of the economy that were
there before regardless of let's forget
for a second the ideological components
and the fact that these were reasonably
pure market people some of them were not
so problematic at and it was a mixture
it was a mixture of a lot of ideological
in policy orientation but the situation
that you have in front of you is that
all the coordinating structure that
cylinders that we saw before are still
there but the structure the coordinates
them and manages them is not there
anymore
and so clearly privatization becomes one
of the alternative to have management
and coordination of the economy and in
order to go so the values state the
various privatization approaches in
Russia I have divided into three types
that are somewhat real and somewhat
ideal the first part is when everything
collapses there is no there is no
concern about property rights all that
people are focused on is appropriating
the cash flow that will come out of
those cylinders cash flow is a focus in
a system that collapses will you worry
about your will you worry about your
property rights now you will worry what
but you see all this cash flow that
becomes available
especially if you go back to the first
slide and if you think that all those
commodities have an international market
so if you find a way to sell them to the
international market you get out of the
trap in which the cash that was
allocated to you was allocated from the
structure of the Soviet Union to buy the
few goods that were available you get
the cash you get some of these resources
you sell them in the world market you
get the cash flow physically I mean you
get the cash flow no bank accounts no no
banking system a lot of people a lot of
people are surprised and I was surprised
when I was there about the day about the
economy with the suitcases full of
dollars think about the system that
collapses where there are no bank
accounts every transaction every
transaction has been made with cash and
the cash has been rationed
can you imagine you can sell you can
sell a ship of aluminum and you get half
a suitcase of dollar bills which by the
way you can bring into a complacent
banking system totally outside the
control of anyone
marvelous so the first stage of
appropriate of privatization what get
privatize is only the cash flow simple
basic rational afterward the Reformers
are able to put two pieces of
legislation through the Duma you've read
it you're read bill Browder what is the
first piece the most important piece of
legislation the privatization law the
voucher privatization law that's a
second piece of legislation a piece of
legislation without which it's difficult
to understand what went on was the
corporatization law
Soviet Union since we you go back
ministers party territorial there were
no corporate entities there were no
corporate entities if you think about
state property into any Western nation
the way it is organized is to corporate
entities the state owns 100% of the
shares 60% of the shares 30% of the
shares 20% of the shares there were no
corporation no corporation in the Soviet
Union so there were former that were
irrational they have the corporatization
first or more or less the same time
corporatization and privatizations of
vouchers they are both important in -
they are both important to establish
your property rights and the second
stage of privatization is the attempt to
switch from trying to control the cash
flow to try to control to get the
property rights it looks similar it
looks simple but just to show you how
complex with my D I'm going to give you
a very simplified a very simplified view
of one of the Soviet integrated oil
company let's suppose that I corporate
that nowhere is written that I
corporatize the whole integrated oil
company if I act rationally I can
corporatize some of these entities I can
corporatize the production of code I can
corporate
refining I can corporatize marketing and
I can corporatized shipping and each if
I get my property rights correct each
one of these entity is going to give me
property rights that are valuable and a
cash flow that is significant and so
with the corporatization you created you
created a lot of potentially independent
and profited a profitable entities where
there was a fight for the property
rights of these entities and so the
second stage in the privatization is
assuming I want to own an integrated oil
company how do I get control of one two
three or more of all the stages because
that's where the big prices and so you
have the challenges posed by the
corporatization and the challenges posed
by the voucher system which is vouchers
are going to be distributed if I have
enough vouchers I get control of the
campaign but even more interesting if I
get 25 percent of the vouchers I can
stop anybody else sorry I can stop
anybody else in court I cannot stop if
he comes with guns and if he had more
guns than me
avi or V or if he is backed by the local
police or the Federal Police so the
really big stage in building the
companies that you see today in Russia
and the power and the wealth of the
oligarch is in this stage of course most
of these are people that got control of
the cash flow early but where they built
the empires
is in this stage and after when you have
secured property rights into one of
these corporate entities you start
trying to acquire so alliances and non
alliances or coercion if you can get
coercion or more if you can have more
question resources than the other guy
you start you try to a rebuilt a
corporate a complete corporate entity
I put the loan for share scheme in this
in this phase but that's just because of
the just because I because I like it in
this phase instead of the for what was
the loan for share scheme we have seen
the collapse we have seen the collapse
of the of the Soviet Union before with
the collapse of all these entity where
does the state get a resources first you
have to think that there were very
little taxes being paid in the Soviet
Union because the resources were taken
there sources were taken through the
banking system people didn't pay tax the
bank just took part of waters of war
there and there is redistributed to the
state
these old thing collapse the state has
no resources all the resources are
private so group of people come up with
a brilliant scheme and say to the and
approach Yeltsin and say okay you have
no cash no tax but you need to spend for
the budget we will lend you the money
we private people will lend you the
money but you know lending is a serious
activity nobody'll and unsecured and so
you give us as collateral the shares
into some of the most important
companies that are owned by they are
still owned by the states we loan to you
and we take them as coal at
when the state could not pay though they
appropriated that Coolatta and so
legally the power of the oligarchs if
you want to go to the origin of the
power of the oligarch come from the fact
that with the state that collapse and it
has no economic resources they have the
economic and financial resources they
lend it to the state and in exchange the
state gives them the shares in some of
the most prized companies oil companies
Yukos was built like these Luke oil was
built like this and nor else nickel was
privatized like these and a lot of
others end from this share you get you
get to the third stage which is you
bring the cash flow and the property
rights and the control of corporate
entities together and you build you
build the big empires the big financial
and industrial empires the interesting
one is the fourth one which is the one
that Putin and the new Russian structure
tribe is try
they are only done one and we did it as
Goldman and it's a totally it's a
totally different system which is they
established a state property commission
that owns every almost every state-owned
corporation and that state property
committee decides how to privatize and
they privatized so a selection project
purchase of an agent and that agent has
power of attorney firm the stay
themselves they
entity that needs to be privatized there
is only one example of a big company
being privatized that way and is that
example is it was done in 2000
end of 2013 for beginning 14 I don't
know it doesn't matter it's question of
a month or 2 months and that's a la Rosa
which is the single biggest producer in
the world of diamonds and the way there
was there was a tender for being the
government agent and it was Morgan
Stanley as in JP Morgan that made it to
the final three
and we as Goldman were selected at the
agent and we did the privatization and
the shares were sold on the internet on
the Moscow stock exchange and
international exchange and it was a
reasonably successful one actually very
successful since then none none has been
done we never finished I would skip do
to the automobile the automobile
industry and I will get to leanings
revenge-y leanings avenge Vienna
intervenes because in 1916 laning
published a book called imperialism the
theory of the book is very basic very
simple and on the whole not to be
discarded and that idea the idea came to
yen in because any was obsessed with the
structure of the of the German banking
system in which the banks where de facto
the financier of German industry and
this theory was at the end the final
stage of imperialism is a triumph of
financial capital financial capital will
end up owning anything everything in
manufacturing in consumer
we'll be in the end of all financial
capital that the top ten list of the
more the richest people in Russia in
2004 and the other one is in 2015
each one of them build the Empire so a
bank
oil oil and something else
oil fertilizer in gold nickel oil
natural resources of various type
aluminium oil coal and steel the new
ones
oil oil natural resources of various
type petrochemical and all of them all
of them did it through financial
strategy that was used to solve all the
problems that we have seen before so
that there is what I call Italy a means
of revenge because when the system he
built collapsed it looks like he was
right when he wrote when he wrote
imperialism in 1916 what is that
these are the acronym of 21 security
agencies of the Russian Federation I
don't think that they are all
independent from each other so
independent they are not branches of the
same so if you look at if you look at
Russia you can see 21 different I am NOT
putting the police into these these are
real security agents there is no army
there is no police
these are all security agents I I don't
know a lot of other places where you
have I don't think that anybody knows
the number of people that work for this
so I'm just putting the number of the
most of them are national most of them
are federal and state and so you find
them in every you find them in every
yeah in every Oblast in heaven so if you
are I'm going to finish with something
that is partly see your use and partly
joke we go back to that we go back to
there we go back to the resources to the
natural resources now let's go back to
the Security Agency commentators usually
say that mr. Putin it's doesn't really
have a strategy but he's a great
tactician I I don't know if well
actually I don't know him at all and so
they might be right there might be wrong
I'm going to venture you differ going to
venture you something slightly different
which is that if you think at the Soviet
Union Soviet Union is a system was
really remarkable for two things
the management of these resources and
these security apparatus the people that
we saw before we're very smart and very
capable and went for this slide mr.
Putin even if he didn't have a very even
if he didn't have a strategy
he went for these resources and you know
I will tend out here we tended up those
our resources were incorrectly an
incredible incredible resources I have
not put the system of the judge
the tax police and so on these are just
normally your normal security apparatus
so it was not such a bad strategy
Finnish Cascades many question of the
way in please if you want to ask
question on what I have done for the
last in the last three years and so on
you want to have any idea of our Goldman
is able to operate in in a system that I
tried to describe partly see you're
usually partly not so series but if you
think about it it's not I I put it as a
joke but it's not political scientists
will appreciate their going for the two
different type of resource please thank
you so much for your talk so one of the
points that the Washoe brings up in her
book is that the initial corruption that
occurs during the Yeltsin years is
largely overlooked because a lot of
people in government thought that a
strong state later on could reinforce
rule of law and break down this
corruption so I'm wondering if you could
speak a little bit about your experience
at Goldman with corruption that still
exists in the Russian Federation and why
people in the state might have had that
initial belief that initial corruption
could later on be wiped away by strong
rule of law you are asking a tough
question one because you assume that
there is a rule of law
but let's take your question how would
we operate in a system that's supposed
to be or LEDs exceedingly crap we have
and I and I enforce it very original
we have a system that works the
following way
every business opportunity that it's
available goes through a double filter
there is a business filter that is me in
some of the business people in London
and we decide if that's a business that
we would like to do is it a part is it
profitable is it is it the right thing
for is it what investment bank do but
before that there is another group which
we call business intelligence unit and
business intelligence unit I am I'm on
tape by my program the business
intelligence unit is coordinated by a
gentleman that retired four years ago is
one of the few people that it's public
in the UK he was the coordinator of the
security agencies of the he came from
m16 and it was a coordinator of the
various security agencies of the British
government and the selection to decide
if if the entity that proposes us that
particular business that I think it's
appropriate for an investment bank our
entities that Goldman wants to deal with
it's him if he says no
I don't care how attractive the business
is we just don't do it if he says you
don't talk to that guy
I don't care we don't care our two
active the business can be or are
wealthy
the guy is we just don't do it and I
don't get I don't have those security
qualification and so sometime I get the
evidence that brings him to say no and
sometimes I don't because I don't have
those qualifications those clearances
but that's a way we operate that's a way
I operate there is no there is no other
way and these is even before the
sanction now with the sanction it's I
won't say is easy because a sanction
people are it's clear they are
sanctioned there is nothing we can do
for that
now the second the second part of your
question the second part of the question
is do you still do business yes yes we
do business we do business and it's it's
reasonably it's a reasonably it's a
reasonably attractive business and you
can do business that is not tainted with
people that are with people that are not
on the sanction list and people that are
not that your business intelligence unit
says that you can deal with now their
rule of law I was discussing it today
with Doug the rule of law might be an
exaggeration but I just wanted to give
you give you a data it's not more than
the rule of law in my opinion is the
state appropriate appropriate is I don't
want to give you a wrong term they take
that stage get control of a large number
or
large chunk of their resources that they
did not get controlled in the nineties
the marginal tax rate on oil export it's
depending let's say that is around 90
percent these resources go straight to
the state and they feed these 21
entities and I don't mean feed in the
bad sense in the dervishes sense I don't
know I have no I think it's a great book
of investigative journalism and I think
that it's highly likely that she's 98
percent right I don't have any expect
these are facts I don't deal with these
things so I have no idea but over ninety
percent of the taxes on oil go to the
federal state that's that's a lot that's
large that's large that gives you a lot
of resources in addition to the in
addition to the agencies and so it's yes
ciello if you don't look at it very
carefully you will think that what's
happening to oil price will create a
fiscal crisis for the russian state they
one of the characteristic one of the
macroeconomic characteristic of russia
is that you will find some but not a lot
of currencies that are correlated so
correlated with oil as the ruble and so
when oil goes down the exchange rate
robell dollars goes up that means you
need more obols to get a dollar and so
there is their revenues the amount of
revenue there are two phenomena one is
that the cash flows in ruble that goes
to the oil producer it's not very much
reduced and their revenues in herbals in
rubles that go to the states are not
very much reduced so for instance with
oil at one hundred and ten dollar a
barrel and their ruble at thirty-three
ruble per dollar
it's about indifferent for the producer
and not and there is 10% worsening for
the state then with oil at sixty and
Noble at 57 so that's one of the reason
why the Russian government does not
hedge oil prices in order to guarantee
the revenues that get to them if we get
to if we get to if we get to currency
it's a different story but if you have
significant currency reserves and if you
have a currency and most of your cost
let go that are highly correlated with
the price with the price of oil and you
have a very progressive system on oil
extraction and sale its I won't say
indifferent but it's not so sensitive
the amount of resources that you get on
your federal budget it's protected by
the devaluation of their o board visibly
the dollar and so you are not that your
your capability resources you have are
not
that sensitive - to the to the price to
the price of oil on the world mark a
minute ago they've all read the Browder
book how does it look to you from your
vantage point his argument first is
argument first I have to his argument
relate to a period where I didn't
operate in Russia so it's difficult to
it's difficult to me to judge on on the
basis on the basis of on the basis of
experience I would say it is in line
with a lot of stories that I have with a
lot of stories that I have heard with a
lot of similar stories that I've heard
it what we discuss it what what I find
odd to some extent is someone that
clearly was so capable in understanding
the characteristic of the Russian system
in the 90s had so much difficulties in
understanding the characteristic of the
Russian system after 2000 I still on
tape am i I would say I will give you an
example I will try to give you an
example one
b.p head and still has BP British
Petroleum it's probably of the oil
majors is probably the one that has the
biggest Russian footprint and the
Russian footprint of BP was in a joint
venture with alpha dope in tnk-bp when
with mr. Putin and mr. Satan decided to
get more control of the oil industry BP
and a Russian oligarch that were partner
of BP in in tnk-bp where they didn't
want to sell but they were asked to sell
to Rosneft the state-owned oil company
headed by mr. Sager and which is
interesting of the way in which many of
these things are done in Russia the
three shoulder BP where the threshold of
tnk-bp were offered each one of them was
offered different deal none of this
behavior of treating every shareholder
and the same every shoulder on the same
basis the Russian shoulders were offer a
lot of cash and I mean cash BP was
offered some cash and a large chunk of
share in hours left with two board seats
the minority shoulders well offer we're
offered less than the valuation of
number one of the share of the cash
given to the Russians and the shares and
in the exchange of shares given to BP
and everybody around the table probably
with the exception of the small shoulder
understood what the game was and took
the deal I am really surprised at a man
that smart did not understand that those
were the new rules of the game you don't
go to jail you don't get shot you are
given a significant amount of benefits
but not everything you would like and
you were just asked to you know be quiet
and toe the line sorry I'm very cynical
as you can you can understand doesn't
mean I approve it's just an an elite I
think that approval or it's a different
it's a different order I think that if
you are in this kind of line you have a
duty to yourself and you have a duty to
the organization you work for to
understand exactly what's going on
afterward you might decide to play you
might decided not to play you might
decide to get out you might decide a lot
of thing but the duty that you have is
to understand exactly what's going on
and there is no excuse for not doing it
you should you should be in a different
you should be in a different line of
work
if you refuse to do that or if you don't
do it sorry thank you very cynicism it's
our you know it's absolute cynicism that
and there is no value judgment I'm not
criticizing anyone it just I was also
very surprised that mr. bratter did not
learn how to speak Russian
having lived there for 10 years neither
do I still time and I know no I'm out as
of the end of December no time for me no
time so just based on your presentation
it seemed to me that once the Soviet
Union collapsed you Institute and
introduce these drastically new
overarching institutions through the
voucher program through the
incorporation law that have never
formally existed before so very few
people in the Russian public are gonna
have any understanding of what you're
introducing and you have this huge
information asymmetry where only a very
my new group of people who perhaps have
had some exposure to the outside
financial system which at that point
would probably be former KGB officers
who had been allowed to set up bank
accounts outside of Russia and had some
understanding of how outside economies
work would have kind of an information
advantage and at least through the
Browder book it seemed like there is
very little transparency in the voucher
programs and that there were small
minority groups that were able to go and
kind of con the Bowsher system and
really not only take over companies but
take over parts of industries or entire
industries so my question really is if
that is the system that essentially has
remained in place where there still is a
no now is no now is different it is
different no it's it's different I think
that you are making I think that you are
making a very interesting and a very
valid point
but I think that you have to you have to
distinguish between two different things
one is the availability of those
information one is an information
asymmetry the other is what you are
going to be able to do or not to do with
the information you have
and the reason why I went to the four
stages of privatization is that the
appropriation of the cash flow it's not
a question of information it's just a
question of the position where you are I
think that everybody I think that
everybody would have been looking at the
suitcase full of dollars even if you
didn't have any idea about the
capitalist system of work it is just
that some of the 14 million people that
were working in that structure has the
ability to get to appropriate the cash
flow and others did not
that in my opinion is the defining is
the defining characteristic more than
information asymmetry so it's more a
question of position than of knowing
because the basic the basic thing that
you need to know is that is a suitcase
full of dollar is better than an empty
suitcase but not everybody could get a
suitcase of dollars and it is not a
question of KGB or not kick away
actually people that got very wealth in
this stage very few of them are very few
of them are KGB operatives very few or
none of the
the only one the only one here that you
could identify to some extent with
public a public position is this guy
that was that was anybody was a minister
in one of the government during the
Yeltsin president all the others none of
them none of them is none of them as
none of them is well known history with
with Security Agency or history with
history with the government entities but
I take your point on similar information
asymmetry is more important in the stage
afterward when we when we get to when
you get to merging the cash flow and the
property rights that's where and
actually one of these gender all of this
debt that's where that where all of
these people got rich by using by using
the banks and by using a financial
structure to build industrial and
financial empire and that was an
advantage due to information and
understanding of how the word outside
Russia worked and the role of Bank the
role of financial engineering and the
fact that you can get controlled you can
get control of another entity either by
sending sacks whose ak-47 or by finding
a way to buy 51% of the shares or sorry
76% of the shares most legit not not
legitimate but most effective strategy
um I had a question about the Gustafson
reading which seemed to get across one
of the main points that while initially
especially in the early 2000s a lot of
economic leaders thought that Putin was
moving towards a more sort of
free-market system ultimately at least
by 2005 it became clear that the
economics were serving the state and
this doesn't seem to have really changed
up until now if this is a premise that
you accept what do you think businesses
and banks should be doing in Russia and
how should they think of the risk
effectively that ultimately the economic
system is going to be secondary to the
state apparatus should there be a
relationship with the government with
other particular kinds of businesses are
you asking me what my philosophy is or
are you asking me how to survive
possibly prosper in Russia there might
be two no there might be two totally
different question
some people have known me for a long
time and so they know what my policy
preferences 19th century liberal
capitalism 19th century so 20th century
is already polluted by too much state in
my view and so you get it so you get an
idea but today if I think it is
depending where you are depending in
which industry you are but I think that
if you are in in unless if you are in
retail if you are in consumer oriented
good I don't think that you were a
relationship
with the government we go back we have
to go back to the pyramid I don't think
that your relationship with the
government are going to be vital in
being a successful entrepreneur I think
you can build you can probably build an
advanced distribution system an advanced
system of hypermarkets without having
more more state intervention than in a
lot of other Western European countries
it's strong it's not as positive as it
sounds because there are no change to
repair my car market in Italy or in
France because you don't get because you
will not get licenses from their regions
and they in the cities because because
the voters are small small businesses
and so they will not give you a license
to open an IPO market because you're
going to put them out of business so we
will be very careful but I don't think
that in Russia you need to have
particular protection from the
government to develop a retail or
strategy when you get to natural
resources and heavy industries are
different it's a different ballgame it
is a different book is it is it
radically different than from other
nation that I know of qualitatively and
quantitatively yes it is
the tells you object of the 20 of the 20
people that I that I put on the the one
that do not have a good relationship
with the government or don't have a
great relationship with the government
my own tape again I would prefer to turn
it off now I mean this is a lot of
people making the same argument the
sanction are not wanna they are not
deadly to they are not they are not
causing any inconvenience they are just
no I don't think so
which inconvenience quote me an
inconvenience no I can quote you several
inconvenience is difficult to come to
the United States that's it for some of
them was difficult before for different
reasons and so it's it's it's a matter
of degree what they convey what the
inconvenience you have you have no no no
western bank will finance you okay fine
will will Russian banks financier of
course it will finance you even a better
terms okay you will not get you will not
be able to erase you will not be able to
erase equity on the on a Western stock
market are going to be are going to be
able to get are you going to be able to
get reasonably mmm if if you are well
diversified are you're going to AB are
you going to be able to have good
infrastructure project within within the
Russian Federation that is going to be
significantly profitable yes you are so
it's just a different distribution of
benefits sorry but I'm very cynical as
you can get so question about financial
reporting and financial transparency the
concept of corporate reporting was of
course non-existent in 92 and then they
started to worry about tax reporting in
98 etcetera now we're at a point where
supposedly that IR for us is you know
the accounting rules are selectively
adapted and we have auditors but one
gets a sense oftentimes that's even with
that the investment decisions and the
lending decisions are not really based
on the on these reports which are maybe
not worth the paper they're printed on
it it's everything is still kind of
nudge nudge wink wink you know what
other information do you know who do you
know etcetera so are we finally at a
point where Russia's financial reporting
has an actual valid role comparable to
to you elsewhere the goldman sachs
perspective of personal perspective kind
of whatever is it the same it is in the
united states no is it better than it
was before yes so one of the thing one
of the thing that you one of the thing
that you learn in russia unfortunately
is that it's up and down all the time
that you are faced you're faced with a
reality that will positively sort
prize you one day on one aspect and will
turn out to be or another aspect will
turn out to be deadly or horrible or
unpleasant the day after or another
aspect of the same another aspect of the
same phenomenon no I mean I think that
on I think that on reporting on
financial reporting they have done they
have done incredibly they they have they
have moved I mean almost every almost
every big almost every big company now
has as financial reporting done by en Y
or and that that are there are there are
I think on the whole accurate and
reliable now do they get do they have
access to lending from Russian bank
which is totally different and totally
more favorable than the one that they
will have from international bank yes
they do
but you have you have both thinks that
the same you're both thinking the same
at the same time or at different times
and so it is more it is more it is a
more capitalistic system than it was 10
years ago 15 years ago or when I went in
91
of course miles away miles closer to if
you draw a continuum
it is mile closer to to an anglo-saxon
type of capital miles does it also have
Oz all of this character all of the
characteristics depicted by these books
in addition of in addition of the one
that actor yes but you know bad and good
and different leave together in the
setting the same nation or in the same
system most of the time
a brief question if you take all of that
and add the demographic picture which is
pretty grim I think that they tell me
that the demographic is changing a
little bit
I don't know is that yeah yeah they tell
me that he's someone with a market it
depends what do you mean by getting
better you might you might have a
different you might you might you might
have you might have different criteria
here a lot more not these not on tape
will you consider more people to work
engage a benefit if they come from
Dagestan and Chitina or not for me
doesn't make any difference from mr.
Putin probably does anyway so am I on
tape no so but no but they tell me no
they tell me what they tell me is that
it but I haven't seen the statistics so
and I don't know how reliable it is but
government officials say that it is
getting better and our Russian chief
economist tells me that it's getting
better it's not as green that it was
there is a phenomenon that also people
live longer and so you really have to
dwell into you really have to dwell in
two very complicated statistics because
because because it's you know the aid
their life expectancy until a few years
ago was very low and now the life
expectancy it's significantly higher and
so that says of course one impact and
and in the birth right but they tell me
that the birth rate is going
I don't I cannot tell you if it is so I
cannot tell it with their stuff
definitely is going I think in the
regardless of every attempt to reduce
the number of Chechens its it's
definitely going in in the in the Kalka
index in the Caucasus definitely but no
immigration do you think these Russian
oil companies and defense industries
they are well run now they effectively
owned by the state right do you think
Austin F is owned by the state but
Lukoil for instance is private do you
think it take a big integrated oil camp
they are not owned by the state Lukoil
is owned by mr. Alec Peres so and by in
and by international and institutional
investor because it's quoted in the on
many stock exchanges including the US
dollar sir
so do you think Rosneft is a well-run
company I wonder I can't judge I can't
if I have to judge of the multiple C
trade I would say that I would say that
the market believes it is not well-run
so they're leaving a lot of money on the
table by doing this kind of state
capitalism I mean from an efficiency
perspective they could do better the
whole economy everybody could do better
but definitely they could do better on
the other hand on the other hand again
their arsenal for today it's doing a lot
better than there was enough of a few
years ago didn't even exist a few years
ago so it it is difficult to generalize
it is very difficult it is very very
very difficult
or happiness or happy or happy in a
different way or happiness if only
because if you think if you think if you
think at the start of consumer that was
only get enough cash to buy the few
goods that were offered few Goods little
cash little cash few Goods the reality
that they are now regardless of where
you are in the income distribution
regardless of where you are in the
distribution of income it's a totally
different world that's in itself because
we sometime we think that the popularity
of mr. Putin is due to being in Syria or
being in or being in or being in Ukraine
but if you had been in Moscow and I went
there in 1991 because I couldn't go
before because they the West did mean to
go there and I don't think they would
have given me a visa but definitely the
West didn't want me to go there there
was not one shop there was not one light
it was dark at 2:30 in February because
they still had the Russian they still at
the Soviet time zone in which to make
Russia more distant from the West there
was one more hour different we didn't
exist in it exist in physics but it
existed it existed on the clock at least
on the Soviet clock you could not buy
anything because of the two monetary
system if you go to Moscow now which is
not a paradise and in fact I want to get
out but restaurants are either libraries
movies reasonably free not free but
reasonably available reasonably
available Internet
after some if you try to get on some
sites it gets a lot slower even in my
apartment gets a lot slower than on
others or a lot slower than in the West
it's it's it's different and people
believe they are leaving a lot better